Adam Lambert is celebrating Halloween
this year by bringing the Witch Hunt
tour to Las Vegas for a three-show
limited engagement I was so excited I
got to catch up with the
singer-songwriter to find out what's in
store for the shows
after dazzling fans on American Idol
season 8 Adam Lambert went on to be an
icon in pop rock music I was like okay
they need a rock guy I like rock music
let's do it you know so I I definitely
was The Rocker that year and I knew what
that meant even taking on the role as
the lead man in Queen opening doors to
unimaginable possibilities well recently
over the summer I did the the Platinum
Jubilee for Queen Elizabeth who as we
know is not with us anymore but it was a
real honor to be a part of sort of the
last big event around her Reign but now
it's time to cue the Vegas show The
Witch Hunt and there's a lot of coverage
that I'm doing this year that I've never
sung before so it's a lot of new first
time material for me so I think fans are
gonna have a lot of fun so we come for
the music but we stay for The Outfits
what can we expect from the costuming
that's what I'm excited about
yeah you know me like you know I don't
do things in a subtle way I you know and
Halloween is you know it's October 1st
it's Halloween you know I'm like yeah
while subtle isn't in Adam's vocabulary
representation is I I realized really
quickly like that that I've been sort of
put in a position whether directly or
indirectly where I was gonna have to
represent people which is how his
feel-something foundation came about and
a way to represent the lgbtq plus
community and so over the years I've
worked with a lot of different
um charitable organizations like kind of
Moonlighting with them and doing events
here and there and it finally just
seemed like it was the right time to
develop My Own Foundation from one goal
to another Adam still has something to
check off his bucket list I want to sing
the national anthem at the Super Bowl
that's what I want to do
I love it but for now his Vegas show is
at the top of his to-do list you know me
it's like it's it's it's it's it's
fashion it's it's heightened fashion and
it's
um it's out there I mean I'm gonna have
fun with it I think it'll be great and
the visuals are amazing we have a screen
behind us we have beautiful visual
accompaniment and yeah I think it's
going to be a good time and one thing
that's for sure Adam Lambert will always
be here for our entertainment
[Music]
Adam Lambert The Witch Hunt at encore
theater is happening October 26th 28th
and 29th